[Music]
is this right you and Tom were both in
in London oh yeah and I have to ask you
you and Tom okay were there and
apparently there was a bit of you were
at Buckingham Palace that's right and
Andy and I don't go off and the
Buckingham Palace when we do were asked
quickly to leave but you two were
invited and you had an interaction with
the yeah and before going to the palace
you are given a whole set of things that
you can do and can't do and how to
address them and how not to address them
and you're not allowed to speak to any
of the Royals unless they speak to you
first that very lockdown these are very
locked down I mean you even had to wear
like closed toed shoes and women had to
wear hose right you know at any point I
thought maybe somebody was gonna come up
and go daughter Karen daughter Karen
because I mean you know there's hose
right right I had to buy some and so I
in a lull after I had been introduced
him and he had shaken my hand I was just
sort of you know standing there and he
wasn't talking and I wasn't talking so I
turned to him and I said I excuse me
your honor I don't know how I believe
that you and I have some shared common
heritage I'm half Greek because you know
he used to be called Prince Philip of
Greece right so I said you know trying
to have some conversation you know we
were sharing something here we're both
half Greek and he turned to me and he
said oh sorry for you then he turned
around and he walked away and I swear my
face turned as red as the carpet that I
was walking on it was so mortifying
that's when you should have said Jack
yeah
God so he never now is that his
sensitive humor or was he really icing
you he's known for having a very very
peculiar sense of humor and subsequently
a friend sent me a website of all of the
things that he has said like that two
heads of state and people all over the
world he just loves screwing the people
he does I think he does big story you
have joined HBO's girls yes this season
- this is like the coolest show on
television you've joined the cast that's
got to be very exciting it's really
exciting
I play Marnie's mom who is Allison
Williams character right and it's a very
I like I like the relationship that they
have and I'm excited to be part of that
I mean those girls are fun they're also
that show takes it to the edge and
that's a show where people are naked I
mean there's just all kinds of stuff
happening on that that's right I'm ready
are you ready today you're ready to
handle that I'm afeared no I didn't know
you were Hill folk